[Musique]
[Rires]
no
[Musique]
rien deux ans maintenant poussins mixtes
ce travail c'est à dire en disant on va
reposer un plat tous les sujets qui
préoccupent les français pas ce qui nous
préoccupe au quotidien ne sphère
politique mais ceux qui font le
quotidien des français
[Musique]
après avoir depuis deux ans gagner
toutes les élections territoriales les
municipales les départementales les
régionales avoir renforcé notre groupe
parlementaire au sénat nous sommes
aujourd'hui la seule force d'alternance
aux républicains face à emmanuel macron
et faso au pouvoir en place il nous faut
maintenant désigner notre candidat pour
porter nos couleurs au moment de
l'élection présidentielle ce sera chose
faite le 4 décembre prochain à
l'occasion d'un congrès numérique vous
avez jusqu'au 16 novembre pour nous
rejoindre au républicain vous inscrire
sur nos listes électorales du parti des
républicains est donc pouvoir participer
à la désignation de notre candidat le 4
décembre prochain
[Musique]